我觉得讲这个词很抽象
其实他讲的实际中是非常的简单
就是我们刚才在寻路中
我们不是找到了一条路径吗
在路径好像一般来讲
我们能找到最优的那个路径
对不对
但是说如果今天我给大家一辆车的时候
他真的能够严格的按照
我们的自由路径去行走吗
其实是不可能的
对不对
大家知道车它有一个加速度减速度
它有个最大加速度
最大减速对吧
它不能瞬移
第二个是什么呢
它有个转弯半径
它不能瞬间的改变它的角度
所以我们在路径寻路上找到了一条直线
但是这个车如果车头朝另外一个方向的话
它其实是沿着一条弧线走过来的
诶这个地方就跟大家讲一个很有意思的问题了
就同学们有没有发现我们在玩很多游戏的时候
你会发现那个就是有些NPC
特别是载具类的
这个NPC的话会卡死在一些点
其实这种卡死很多时候都是这个原因导致
就是我寻不寻的
也是严格的在WORKBAREA
但是呢有的时候因为我要加入这种诶
更加符合物理实际的这样一个STERY系统的时候
他可能就走到了一个以前没有规划的区域
那个区域如果很不幸啊
比如说我的这个比如说物理模拟的某一帧tick
它不长大了那么一点点
他就呆在了一个那个unworkable area之后
接下来所有的曲目对他来讲就失效了
有的时候那个经常你会发现有些角
比如说一个一个角色
它被卡死在一个corner里面
他在里面就会反复的抖动
来回转来回转
但不管怎么转
它的steering都转不过来对吧
但现在游戏中这种问题已经越来越少了
但是呢其实在就是五到10年前的游戏中
大家经常可以用这种方法去玩弄这个NPC好
那么这个steering的话呢
实际上啊很直觉
它实际上呢
基本上我们把它归类归类成几个几大行为
一个是second fly
就是说哎追或者是逃对吧
第二个是什么呢
叫做velocity alignment
就是说我我把velocity那个那个那个matching
就是我要把速度对齐
这个C开的福利
大家很好理解对吧
就是我有个目标点
我去追他
或者说有敌人追
我要总要逃
总是背着他逃跑
对不对
这个好像很直觉对吧
那么第二种
这个就是说为什么叫velocity
这个matching的这件事情很重要的
大家发现没有
就是如果我一个东西
它是一个加速和减速的过程的话
我知道我的起始点
我知道我的目标目标点
但我知道我从知识点出发的时候
我是加速速度越来越快
越来越快
但是我到目标点的时候是什么
我得去减速
而且呢当我减速到零的时候
最好你恰好停在了你的目标点
大家想想这件事情在数学上简单嘛
其实数学上你是要处理一下的对吧
这个这个地方如果是一条直线还可以
但如果是一个弧线的运动呢
是不是更复杂
这个东西特别让我想起
以前我我我以前在看那个航天的时候嘛
就是那时候我才懂一个道理
比如说今天我们要发射一个
比如说我们的火星探测器发射到火星上
不是说你的火箭足够大足够猛
速度足够快
我把这个发射器送上去就了事了
其实大家知道
就是当一个就是飞行器到了火星之后
他最难的一件事情是什么呢
那个时候我我我上面已经没有多少燃料了
这个时候我还要浪费我宝贵的燃料
开始减速
要把我的速度变得跟火星的那个绕的那个太阳
公转的速度差不多
当然我我绕着火星自转对吧
我还要保证一定的这个这个不掉下来那个速度
所以这件事情其实是非常非常的难
其实这里面的计算机很复杂
但是它非常像我们的velocity matching的问题
就是说你把这个点送到之后
你还要确保你到了目的地的时候
你的速度几乎跟它几乎是一样的
但这时候我的目标点是静止的
对不对
如果我的目标点是动的呢
他自身就在动
那我要追上他的时候
哎最后我的速度跟他要一致
大家想想这个问题是不是有点意思了
这个就是最后一个就是我的alignment
就是我保证我的这个朝向一致
这也是很正常的对吧
比大家想象一个鱼群对不对
头鱼在那边有其他的鱼都会自觉地跟他并行
比如说我一个飞机编队出去的时候
诶
大家会自然而然就形成一个同向的那个编队
那我一开始的速度可能是不一样的
方向不一样的
但我要跟它AI到一起
所以说其实steering行为的话呢
这三种行为我们认为是最基本的一个行为
那具体给大家讲一下
就是说c can复利
其实呢它要解决的问题
就是说当我的目标点在那边
无论是静止或者动的时候
我会不断地根据我自己的位置
根据我的目标的位置
然后呢确确定我的加速
让我要么就追着那个目标去
要么我就远离那个目标
那这个这个东西讲起来其实也并不难
但大家可以想到就是我在游戏引擎里面
我一个tick
一个tick就tick
你也能得到你想要的这个行为
但这里面second的福利呢其实也有些变种了
比如说这个我们经常讲的pursuit追踪
是一个行为对吧
还有一个是什么呢
叫巡逻
巡逻的话呢
我永远在我前面找一个地方
让他去随机一下
包括这里面呢
我觉得最有意思的行为
是在一个叫速度场或一个方向场里面
一个物体的运动
就是说假设我在空间能够形成一个方向上
方向上叫什么叫victor fw
我把任何一个质点放进去之后
它会沿着方向盘一直在动
诶这个东西其实非常的有意思
其实大家去看一些这种大型的这种群体的运动
模拟的时候
他很多时候是用这种方向场来做的
所以这其实也是一个second fleet的一个变种
所以这个地方比较简单
所以我就不展开讲了
那么另外一个呢就比较有意思的
就是velocity mesh
那实际上的话呢他其实是有一个target的那个速度
我的目标点的速度对吧
我还有什么呢
我的这个我什么时候去那个matching它
我要追上他
这个时候呢
我要反向的用一个一点点积分的方法
反向算出来
我这时候加速了什么
因为这个时候我会根据我目标点
和我的相对速度决定
我靠近它的时候
我要反向去减速
这里面如果目标点它是静止的
或者是匀速直线运动的话呢
这个计算其实是比较简单的
大家想想看
这不就是呃
二分之1T平方等于对方的那个点距离对吧
我就可以开个根号
我能算出来我的加速度是多少
基本上我能保证我能稳稳的停在那个点
但是的话如果对方也是在动
而且是一个非直线的
在动的时候
其实这个we lost the machine的话就非常难了
但其实我自己认为啊
这是你可以假设对方是沿着直线运动的
然后算出一个结果
然后你TK完下一帧的时候
根据它的变化
我再去重新算一个加速度
其实你会形成那个结果呢
基本也能符合你的需求
为什么呢
因为真实的人在世界上行走
比如说你要你的朋友在前面一通乱走
然后呢你试图跟他去AI
跟他matching在一起的时候
你也不会一上来就全部算出来
你也算不出来
对不对
你根据你的经验
根据他现在的速度
你大概感觉自己一个一个速度该怎么走对吧
然后的话呢你走了大概比如说半秒钟
一秒钟之后发现他有变化了
你身体你会下意识的
你的小脑会告诉你有相应的变化
只是我们人的这种计算全是在电光火石之间
但是呢有一点我们非常确信
就是说人类不会算一个复杂的计分方程
我们只是在做一个就是一个小步长的计算
然后呢根据下一个步长来的时候
情况发生的变化
我们会调整而已
所以呢用这种就是叫分布式的这种算法的话呢
你也能得到一个你想要的一个
基本看上去非常自然的这么一个结果
因为我们是在做AI嘛
所以我们只是希望AI体的行为
看上去像像真实一样
那么最后一个呢其实更简单的就是alignment
Alignment
这里的细节是什么呢
刚才我们讲它的速度对吧
是一个叫加速到最大速度
然后呢快接近目标点的时候
或者跟着目标点的速度逐渐一致的时候啊
那我就开始进行减速了
其实online的地方的话
你要做的真实的话
实际上也是就是角速度方面
也有一个叫加速和减速的过程
这样就证明这个案例的时候
我把方向跟它对齐的时候
一开始我要角速度
角加速度对吧
快到我的目标角度的时候
我要有一个角减速度
这个细节其实非常的重要
为什么
就这也是就是我待会我想的就是
其实啊steering这个系统是一个大牛
在很早就提出来了
这个大牛是后面做那个就是swarm
就是封这个这个这个群体系统
群体行为系统的这个这个开开山鼻祖
那么这个东西为什么这么重要呢
其实我在我早期在写这些
这个AI行为系统的时候
我们也很容易犯这个错误
如果大家没有做这个角色
align的这个角加速度和角减速的过程的话
你会发现你的AI的行为是什么
就是这样
它会突然N嗯
就像那个机器人瞬间的转向
当当当
就是你感觉他很不自然对吧
因为我们做的一切的行为都让它自然了
所以说其实你如果发现这个问题的时候
你会发现哦
肯定是align这个steering算法我也没写好
我没有把它记做足够的这个角加速
角减速的处理对吧
所以这也是一个非常有趣的一个东西
基本上的话STERING算法的话比大家想象的要简单
其实这三类基本上囊括了我们steering的重点
但是呢为什么这个同学们单独拎出来讲呢
因为你会发现啊
如果一个人他没有受过系统的游戏
引擎的训练的时候
他很容易在引擎架构中
把这个系统给给那个漏掉
就是他做完了寻路对吧
但做完了比如说AI的决策系统对吧
然后呢让这个东西就比如环境感知系统
这个角色技能动起来
但是呢你会发现他做出来的这个游戏
或者是角色看上去都很僵硬
就像机器人一样
因为他没有加入一个让它更符合人自然行为的
这个steering系统
特别是你在做载具的时候
做这个人类体型为的时候
做生物的时候
这个其实很重要
比如说你模拟一个快速奔跑的一个
这个生物的效果的话
它的惯性对吧
它的最大加速度和它的最大的这个转向速度
其实都是他一个约束条件
基本上这些呢就是我们的series系统
那在这个地方呢我们要荡开一笔
就是说这个系统它的一个大客户是什么呢
就是这个群体系统
就是或者叫做授权系统啊
Crowd simulation
就是说我有很多的东西在一起运动的时候
你该怎么去处理
大家会觉得这件事情好像AI
我们今天不是讲AI吗
为什么上来就讲crowd呢
因为实际上现在AI在很多时候
在游戏中处理的情景
我们是要处理这个群体运动的东西
举个例子
比如说我们做一个三游戏
比如说我一个我的主角走到一个广场对吧
这个广场上你会发现什么
有很多鸽子在地上
你走过去的人的鸽子会啪一下受惊飞起来
那这个鸽子飞起来的行为呢
其实它就是crow的行为
那我们去做我们的环境
大家看到现在所有的游戏里面
我们都会把这个城市会越做越丰富对吧
很多人走来走去
对不对
你可以在一些好的这个demo里面
你可以看到成千成百上千的NPC走起来
而这些人呢走来走去的时候
他其实不是一个一个的个体
他是用一个crowd系统去做出来的
那么这种群体性的行为
在很早以前就以为大牛对吧
RENO的这个这个大牛他就开始研究了
其实他也是提出了stein系统的这个开山鼻祖
他就说其实对你这种群体性的行为
一般我们有三种处理方法
一种是用微观的方法去解决
就是用一个从底向上
就是我定义每一个群体的行为
他们合到一起就实现了我的目标
还有一种方法呢是马就是宏观的
就是我宏观上定义一种大的运动趋势
你们所有人呢按照我的趋势运动
你的结果也是好的
但第三种就是hybrid
就两种方法都有
就是说既有宏观的控制
又有个体的行为
那这个的话呢就是说能解决一些更特殊的情况
那我首先跟大家讲一下这个微观算法
微观微观算法其实呢比大家想象的要简单
实际上就像一个鱼群一样的
他的行为是什么呢
或者我们人吧
其实他无非就这么几个行为
第一我看我离一个人太近了对吧
我要我们之间要产生一个斥力对吧
我们要彼此推开了
我们不要撞到一起
那么呢如果呢我发现我离人群太远了
特别像鱼群的时候
他会说嗯
我好像也不能太那个离群了
那我要加上一个引力
大家发现这个事情很有意思吧
这个我们在以前在学那个弹簧的时候
是不是很像一个弹簧
就是压缩的时候产生视力
拉远的时候产生吸引力对吧
其实就是个弹簧
然后呢
诶还有更复杂的就是你们既然都头朝那个方向
我也希望跟你一起同样的头朝一个方向
其实你用这么一个简单的这个规则啊
你去把很多的AI体放进去之后
他呢就能形成我们想要的这种鱼群的效果
比如说像这里面的这个案例对吧
潜水艇过来的时候
诶我可以看到这鱼群形成这样一个行为
OK其实这个呢就是一个非常简单的基于规则的
这个就是这个这个就是那个群体crowd simulation
那么宏观的算法的话呢
其实就更害了我
他说因为微观的算法呢
它好处是规则很简单对吧
但是它产出的结果确实是不可控的
他也不太受人的影响
他自己你他很适合表演出一大群的东西
自己走来走去很随机
但是比如对于一些更有规则体系上
比如说这个demo就是虚幻五的那个max AI的demo对吧
那我要展示一下在城市的街道里面
他很多的行人走来走去
我希望因为人在大街上是不会乱走的
对不对
我不能像鱼群一样
就是看见人就撞开
就让开
然后呢随机找方向走
那这个行为就很奇怪
那他是怎么做的呢
诶他首先会定义一个
比如说我的一个一个一个一个一个lab对吧
我的各种land的意思就是说各种人行道
或者是那个就是高速上的一条车道
对我定义很多的车道
然后呢我把这个区域分成很多zone graph对吧
然后呢我生成了很多人的形体的时候
他会在这个空间的沿着这个line line去行走
它其实是一套规则体系
那这样的话呢
我会让整个AI的行为会更加的可控
但这里面还有很多其他的处理的
比如说我怎么样避免就是一个一个个体
它会在line之间快速的切换
比如说它本来是往左边走的
他走了
因为避让一个别人
他要让开一点点
结果呢他一下子切到了
就是逆向的那个烂对吧
那就很奇怪了
对不对
他要保持一致性
但是呢我在十字路口
我要让他有有有这个就是分叉的选择
那这个烂之间的话就是怎么去连接
怎么去分叉
它有一套简单的规则体系
但这些都是宏观控制了
然后这时候我把几千上万个A技能
放上去的时候
它其实是follow了我这个line去进行行走
那么这种宏观方法的话
其实在现代游戏引擎中用的还是非常多的
特别是我们的表达这个人类行为的时候
用这个系统会比较多
因为人类的行为真的不像我们叫做无头的苍蝇
那样对吧
他们其实还是隐隐的按照一套规则去走的
那么像这个就是这两种方法结合的方法呢
就是这个microscope吧
那这个其实很简单
他的当时这个提出来
其实我认为也是一个特殊情况
就是他解决
就是说我把这种蜂群或者这种群体
分成一个个小族群
让小族群呢它受一个大的这个指向
比如说我要往左走
我要从那个那个到对方的出生点对吧
我们有一个目标
但是呢每个小个体的自己行为的话呢
还是follow那个rule base的方法生成我们的结果
这个这个里面最典型的一个应用是什么呢
其实就是我们以前玩的那种RTS游戏
比如说大家玩过星际对吧
玩过帝国时代那么经典的游戏
那么你圈出一圈小兵的时候
你会指定一个目标点
说诶我要打那个点
对不对
在这个过程中
你会发现那些小兵他都往那个方向去走
因为它有一条烂控制它
但是每个小兵的移动的话呢
他又是自主决策的
就是基于他自身的入
比如说他看起来债务
每个小兵是自主决策
我怎么去让他的
而不是整体去决策
所以呢这也是一个群体的一个行为
那么这里面的话呢
其实要跟他讲一个很有意思的东西
就是说其实在座所有的虚拟行为
包括STERING系统里面
我们一个很重要的东西
就是我们要避免去碰撞对吧
我们不希望这些小的crowd会overlap在一起
这样看上去非常的不真实
那怎么样去避免碰撞的一个最简单的方法
就给它加力嘛
这个力怎么加
其实很简单
就是说前面讲过了吗
两个东西靠得太近
我就给它产生斥力
对不对
远了我产生吸引力
只要有斥力在的话呢
很多时候你是不会撞到一起了
但是呢我们一般force space的方法呢
其实还有一个很重要的应用
就是说假设我给你一个环境
这里面其实有很多障碍物对吧
大家会说我会用寻路
但是你假设有几千个东西
你同时寻路的话
那个速度是不是会非常的费啊
大家还记得刚才我讲的寻路算法吗
你要去做这种这个A星算法对吧
每一个小个体都算一遍
这个太废了
对不对
然后呢
我要再对他这个这个这个再进行这个pass moon
想想那个烟囱算法是不是也很费诶
这个时候其实有个非常廉价的方法
就是说我对所有的障碍物加一个就是distant field
就是一个距离
想怎么样
这个地方又来了distant field对吧
当我的每个个体
离那个离那个某个账户最近的时候
越来越近的时候
这个distance field的值就会变得越来越小
我产生的这个反向的斥力就会越来越大
这个时候呢你给一个大致的方向啊
这个群体会能模拟那种真实的A人类的
这种移动的行为
所以这件事情呢
在这个模拟这种人类的这个行为
其实非常的有用
这个东西我给大家讲一个游戏之外的意义嘛
就是啊我们经常讲游戏引擎不是在很多地方
这个不只是游戏嘛
比如在数字孪生里面有个很重要的用是什么呢
就是我们设计好了一座城市
或者一个巨大的一个比如电影院对吧
一个办公场所
办公楼
我们要模拟说
当这个电影院或者办公楼发生火灾的时候
人群该怎么去逃跑
那么其实这里面的很多逃亡的模拟
就是用这种force space的方法
就是模拟人群的应用
而且这个模拟的结果呢跟知识的情况下
真的很接近
因为我们人在那种慌乱的情况下的寻目
真的就是看见墙我就不会撞他对吧
看见人我会让一让我尽可能往那个方向去走
所以能形成这样的一个结果
那这个算法呢其实它很粗暴了
这里面的话我要简单的讲一下
一个很高级的算法
叫叫那个就是那个velocity based model
就是基于这个那个就是基于速度对
就是速度的叫那个velocity obstacle
就是速度障碍法的算法生成的这样的一个碰撞
检测
这个方法其实呢我本来我们准备了十几页
但是呢最后我觉得还是不要展开了它
它其实核心的想法是什么呢
就是说哎当我两个物体在运动的时候
我看到别人走过的物体
它会在我的速度域上形成一个障碍
然后呢我要调整我的速度
尽量避开这个障碍
那么它的方法呢
其实VO的方法其实想法非常的简单
就是说我看到一个东西对吧
那如果我判断我在沿着当前的速度
我就会给你形成速度
你和和你形成一个RBO
就是速度障碍产生这个碰撞
那我就赶快调整我的速度
比如往左边调一点
那么RVO呢就real spect的那个呃
那个voice of st奥斯特的这个方法的话呢
实际上就是不仅我让你也得让这样
我们两个相互是公平的
我们一起就让一下
那这样的话呢就是说其实最简单的做法
就比如说这个时候A发现我要撞上B了
A决定往左拐
B呢这时候意识到说诶你也要撞上我了
那我也亡往应该是往往左拐
这样的话我们两个对吧
行人车辆都靠左行啊
靠左行还是靠远
应该是靠靠左行
这样我们彼此就完美的让开了
但是这个方法呢其实讲起来是不是很简单对吧
但实际实现起来很麻烦
然后呢这个方法它会出一个问题
就是说当这个我们参与的个体不止两个的时候
刚才我们讲的你要处理蜂群对吧
那我们就是A对B的
必然可能会对A对C的必然产生冲突了
就是说你虽然让开了B
但是你可能和C撞到一起了
所以这个时候的话呢
他要做一个整体的优化
这时候就提出了一个著名的叫ORVO
就是optimal
这个方法讲起来就非常复杂了
就是他把空间上的就是这个所有的速度
假设一个时间里面形成了一个就是速度空间的
一个像羽毛球形状的一个一个一个锥形区
那一个区域的话呢
每个人的区域之间
他用那个明可复合求了他们一个和
然后求它里面一个最小的一个
对大家所有最公平的一个时机点
这个听上去是不是很数学
说实话这个地方的数学还是蛮深的
但是呢我要跟大家讲的一件事情
就是说
其实在我们在做引擎的早期的时候
我们把全套的RVO和OO的算法
我们都实现了一遍
但今天我们会发现一个很有意思的事情
就是说RO算法首先在实现上非常复杂
很容易做错
第二件事情呢他处理的不好
计算复杂度其实非常的高
但是呢他确实可以在理论上找到一个最优解
就像刚才那个一上来给大家看的那个视频中
这些小球的运动就是给大家看一下啊
就是这个小球的运动
就是说如果你有这样一个围成一圈的小球
他怎么穿过彼此到各自的目的地
这个优化问题其实是蛮难的
那么就是用OOOOO算法的话呢
基本上能得到一个理想解
但是的话呢其实在真实的游戏引擎中
至少我自己现在的实践
我会更推荐用force space的方法
非常简单
非常好调
但是呢它的结果没有这么漂亮
没有这么elegant对吧
所以的话呢就大家在实现自己的游戏心的时候
你们可以根据自己的选
根据自己的那个判断
那比如说在现在的商业引擎里面的话呢
一般这两种方法都会提供
那大家会觉得很奇怪了
为什么这个东西会变成一个引擎的标配呢
因为在引擎里面
我们真实的支撑游戏产品的时候
我们一般都会有大量的NPC个体
就是你的AI系统会有大量NPC
然后呢这个NPC在运动的时候
我们希望他们有一些群体的行为的合理性
同时的话呢我们又不希望他们彼此产生碰撞
但他会说我不希望那个就是说产生碰撞的时候
那我们是不是会就是说哎用AI来解决呢
其实AI是能解决
但是AI解决这个问题效率是非常非常低的
所以我们需要一个专门的叫clean avoidance
就是碰撞避免系统
来帮助我们AI来解决这个问题
大家看有点意思了吧
就是讲到这个地方已经讲了将近一个半小时了
我们还没有讲到决策算法
因为这些东西其实是决策的一个基础好
那这个我们就不卖关子了
同学们还在讲
我还我还想学AI
对不对
那我接下来给大家讲一个
就是当我们去做AI的最后一个这个基础
就是他的AI的foundation叫做对环境的感知叫森林
那么SENORING的话呢
其实我觉得有我自己喜欢交流词叫perception
就是说感知世界
就是我们人在做所有决策的时候
其实它的基础是什么
要根据我看到的东西
我听到的东西
包括我对自己的感觉
比如说我现在感觉很好
感觉良好对吧
或者感觉不好
那么基于这所有的信息
我才能做出我的行为
我的决策
所以今天我们在所有的游戏引擎里面
看到这AIT的所有的行为
他最重要的一个就是说决策的依据
就是说而且这个依据是动态的
就是对世界的感知perception
那么perception的内容呢
它会分为就是由内到外
累的话就是我自己的状态
比如说我的血量对吧
我现在的速度对不对
我是我的手上的武器里面还有没有子弹对吧
这些东西
那么还有什么呢
还有就是说环境
比如说这个A点到B点到底能不能到达对吧
比如附近有没有一些有意思的点
还有就是说敌人在哪里
有没有敌人对吧
所以这就是很重要的这个AI决策的依据
perception系统不像大家想的那么简单
就是说它实际上的话就是啊
是需要我们整个game play系统
去在设计上去支持好这件事情
那么perception的话
首先的话呢我要能拿到我自己的信息
对不对
我的血量
我的这个装那个armor的这个状态
那么其实呢这个对自己的信息的访问是非常快
非常廉价的
但是大家还记得我们在前面
game play统讲了一件事情是什么懒
比如说像那个蓝图对吧
像visual scription这个系统
它最重要的就是我能读取很多环境的变量
其实这里面有很大的一块变量
就是我自己的状态
那么这个东西为什么他要能支撑论文
因为你没有这个东西的话
其实我后面所有的AI决策都是随机的
它是没有任何基于这个环境的依据的
那么另外一个的话呢
我们还这个要获取的是什么
就是空间的信息
那空间的信息呢
第一种是静态的空间信息
这件事情非常的重要
大家一定要理清楚
比如说我可以是那个navigation
可以这个巡逻的这个我可以动的这个区域
就刚才我讲work by area
对不对
还有是什么呢
就是我的战术地图这件事
这个概念的话
他前面没有介绍过
就是说其实在一个真实的游戏的关卡里面
比如说我形成生成了所有的这个通路区域啊
实际上对AI决策来讲是不够的
举个例子
比如说我的整个这一个
比如说一条河中间有座桥
河桥的两岸都是开阔地
那么它可通行的区域是不是很大
那今天如果我们去深设计一个AI
这个AI后来要来去这个跟你去对抗的时候
我们的人是不会天然就会意识到说
那个连接河两岸的那个桥的两头
是一个重要的战术点
对不对
那个所以呢这个时候呢在AI系统里面
我们就会要求设计师形成一个叫text map
你要手动标记那些地方
是一个更具有战术价值的点
那么AI在做决策的时候
他会优先去控制和那个区域
优先消灭那些虚拟的敌人
那么这个txt map的话当然真的展开比较复杂了
就是说它存的数据的维度是非常多
另外一个的话呢就是在这个游戏的世界里面
我们的设计师会放放很多可以交互的东西
比如说我们一般叫smart object
比如说那个地方有个梯子
AI就知道到
那我会把这个梯子支起来对吧
或者说那个地方有一座墙
那个墙是可以被打破的
那我AI就知道说我可以
如果我想去达到某个战斗
结果我可以用我身上的某个武器把那个墙打破
给我的给人类玩家提供一条通路
对不对
那么还有什么呢
还有就是说啊我们有一些就是说在游戏中
其实周边那个txt map也重要
就是我会标记说有些地方是你可以掩护的
掩护点对吧
就大家最著名
大家记得以前那个就是最早我印象最深
就是最早做的很好的
让我非常impressive的一个游戏
就是战争机器
因为那个时候我们在做FPS的时候
AI都是跳来跳去
跳来跳去
战争机器里的AI都会躲在树洞后面
拿着枪这样去去打别人对吧
然后你会觉得哇这个AI看上去很智能
因为我们人类很多时候进入到一个战场的时候
我会首先去找掩体对吧
所以说其实在游戏地图上
有很多分散的这个special的information
空间上的这些信息
这些信息都是由我们的设计师预先构建好
那么接下来呢还有很多动态的信息
这个信息的话呢实际上也是AI的foundation
那么这里面有一个很著名的一个
也是一个很重要的概念
叫做influence map
就是这个影响力图或者叫热力图
或者叫叫叫什么因子图吧
就是说其实我们的AI
在对于战场态势进行感知的时候
他的基于的就是这个influence map
举个例子
比如说当那边有很多敌人
当敌人越来越多的时候
我们可能会把那个地方的敌人比较危险系数
那个维度会逐渐的提的很高
然后呢这样的话
当我的AI如果发现自己哎我残血了对吧
他就会下意识的让自己避开
那怎么知道我要避开那个区域呢
它其实是要query这个inference math
说我要去的目标点
比如从A点到B点
但这个地方的话
有一个就是威胁系数很高的区域
我会想办法绕开它
如果威胁威胁
那是中等
我可能选择消灭它
如果位置很低的话
我就选择直接闯过去
其实这个东西的话是对那个AI
在整个战场的行为影响是非常大的
另外一个的话是什么呢
就是这个诶动态的寻路
前面讲的就是为什么寻路要动态
因为当游戏里面的这些就是其他的玩家也好
或者是其他的AI好
产生了一些行为之后
或者游戏里发生了一些重要的event
一些事件的时候
那么就是说你会发现就是说我的AI的行为
决策就会发生变化
那么我的AI对这个世界的动态的感知
也非常重要
否则的话你会发现AI
他永远是按照一个套路去打对吧
它不会根据我们真实在这个世界里发生的行为
有变化
那么包括呢就是我的视野
就是在这个世界里面的话呢
其实这个视野也会发生很多的变化
所以其实啊就是动态的空间信息
也是他的感知
也是我们AI运算的一个基础
所以这几个概念我今天因为时间的关系
我没有展开
但是大家会发现讲到这儿的时候
其实呢引擎会提供一部分的功能
但是呢很多时候是根据你不同的游戏
有游戏开发者自己来设计
但是引擎这边的话呢是要提供一个开放的接口
就是当我们在设计AI角色系统的时候
它一定要有一个通用的方法访问这些数据
比如说前面讲到的哎
我的各种自我的变量或者环境的变量对吧
包括你其实在根据game play
我会更新很多的这种influence map
一般来讲infant map是非常复杂的
它有很多的维度
就是对这个世界的状态进行表达
那么我们在这个AI系统里面对吧
要提供一个通用的接口包
让我们的决策树能够访问这些数据
所以这个地方的话呢
也是各个游戏团队的一个功力
就是你的AI做的好
做的坏
这个地方的设计是很重要的
但是呢引擎测也要提供你的功力
就是说你的这个接口扩展性要足够强好
那么其实呢另外一个很重要的动态的空间信息
就是这个游戏里面的物体对吧
那最简单的就是说我现在站在这儿
我得看到说有多少人在我面前
我要感知到这些人存在
同时的话呢我在判断哪些人是我的敌人
因为我只有知道我的敌人有没有
敌人在哪里
敌人跟我的距离的远近
还有什么呢
哎敌人对我的威胁度
他拿了什么武器
是不是我打不过他对吧
所以这个时候你要干嘛呢
你要找到那些物体的id
你要判断他是不是可见了
甚至你需要知道他是不是看得见你对吧
包括你最后一次这个探测他用的什么方法呀
这些东西都会影响到我AI的决策
其实这个东西为什么叫CSIN呢
就是对世界的感知呢
因为你会发现
我们这个为AI系统构建了这个
基础感知体系的话
它在这一趴的话非常像我们人类对世界的感知
那么这里面的话呢就就这里给大家一定要强调
就是在我们做做AI的时候
经常会犯一个错误
就是有两种错误
第一种错误呢
我们会认为我们的AIT整个世界是开图的
就是没有战争迷雾的
比如说大家作为一个RTSS的AI的时候
最早的时候做的时候就会有一个假设
就是地图上发生的一切我都知道
比如说大家最早以前玩那个啊
比如说像那个啊cs的这个AI bot的时候
早期做的比较傻的时候
那个bot他是全图全开的
就是机器人永远知道你藏在哪儿
这会让你很绝望
你做所有的战术的躲藏动作
对他来讲都是无效的
人家就直直勾勾的冲着你扔雷
冲着你打枪
对不对
这种AI你们觉得好玩吗
不好玩对不对
那么我们希望的AI像什么AI像人一样
那人对世界的感知就比较有趣了
第一个是视觉
很自然
对不对
我们可以机器人
它比如说一个bot
它背对你的时候
你居然会觉得我可以从背后偷袭他
对不对
为什么
因为机器人他的朝前他是有视野的
但是呢我是不是可以冲过去偷袭他呢
哎这件事又不行
为什么呢
因为他还有听觉对吧
就是说它的听觉是360度的
那么这个听觉呢又是一个很重要的感觉
如果讲的更更加精细一点
就是说你这个听觉的范围
还不是一个完整的语言
为什么你隔着一些障碍物的时候
可能声音有一个阻碍的效果对吧
比如说你躲在草丛里面
你的声音传播的就会受影响
所以当我们想做一个非常好玩的一个
战术游戏的这个AI的时候
实际上你会让AI模拟这个很像人类的行为
但这里面讲的更夸张点说
我们要模拟一下AI对嗅觉的感知呢
理论上是可以的
但是呢好像现在游戏中用的这个很少
但是说不定将来以后有个什么游戏
就是里面有一个嗅觉特别灵敏
比如说一只狗对吧
他可以听到很轻的声音
能够顺着你留下的味道一直闻下去
那么这个里面也会做这样一个无感的东西
所以说这个其实啊对世界的SENSELLING
是我们的AI系统的一个foundation
这也是一个啊非常重要的游戏统
那当在在做的330的时候呢
你做最基本的算法其实并不难
但是比较容易出问题的一个地方
就是在引擎里面比较容易出的地方是什么呢
就是说如果我们给每一个bot都在
每一帧都在做这个世界的perception的话
perception本身会成为世界的性能瓶颈哈
所以这个事情是当我们在做引擎的时候
其实这个地方我们一般会开放两件事情
第一个就是说开放给这个游戏产品
你会选择不同的情景下
你对世界340的精度
你340的范围
这样的话
能够把这个计算机的这个成本压到最低
另外一个的话呢
也就是说
我们实际上会尽量的把一些对世界的感知
如果临近的那个bot的话
我们会共享
这样避免就是说对吧
一群小也就一群boss
在那时候大家每个人都算一遍
那这个世界就会变得非常的麻烦
但是这里面就是一些工程上的细节了
但是的话呢这个340系统的foundation
也是游戏引擎系统做AI的一个重要的基础
讲到这一趴的话呢
我们就可以终于进入了
也是我们今天课程的最后一排
就大家会发现就是我们讲AI的话
实际上我的课程百分之啊
可以说是70%到80的部分
并没有讲大家最想听的
如何让电脑这个让那个bot变得聪明
大家只听到一大堆的基础系统
但是就像我前面讲的
就是如果没有这些foundation的话
其实AI是不能做任何事情的
所以这就是AI的foundation好
那接下来这一趴的话呢
我们就会讲一些经典的decision making算法好
其实角色算法呢是AI算法的核心
就是前面讲的所有东西都是它的基础
那么决策算法呢
最基础的最最常见的一个东西是什么呢
就是这个有线状态机对吧
我相信这个是大家的一个老老朋友了
因为在那个就是我们讲动画呀
讲前面的很多系统的时候都讲到这个概念
那么今天重点会跟大家讲的是一个叫行为术
行为术也是一个AI最核心的一个体系
那其实在现代游戏中
还有很多其他的这个角色算法
比如说这个HTN对吧
就是那个层次这个任务
这个网络还有那个就是GP
就是那个就是基于目标的目标驱动的
这样的一个就是行为的计划系统
就是go orange的那个action planning系统
就是GP
还有什么呢
蒙特卡罗那个那个那个搜索数
这也是非常经典的一个架构
包括大家很关心的这个deep learning
基于现在人工智能这些深度学习的方法
我们能不能做AI
但是呢今天这节课
我想这这些算法在我的理解中
但是这些里面完全是我的一家之言啊
我会认为就是说像状态机也好
像行为术也好
它更像是一种forward planning
就是说就是从前往后
慢慢就是这个我叫做脚踩西瓜皮
走到哪是哪了
这种决策过程
那么像后面要提到
比如像HTM
像这个GP
像这个就是蒙特卡罗的方法
像那个deep ne
更像是一个就是以目标为驱动的一个反向算法
就是因为我要完成一个目标
所以我要做以下几个动作
所以这些算法会更有意思一点
所以呢我今天就卖个关子
就是说我把这些最有趣的东西
放到我们的下一节课
而今天呢我先把最经典的前项的这样的一个
决策算法给大家讲清楚
那么首先的话呢让大家见识
来来再温习一下我们的老朋友叫状态机
其实状态机非常的简单
也是非常符合人类的直觉
就是我们认为就是整个一个AI的行为
不就是在状态一状态二之间来回切换嘛
对不对
当条件满足的时候
我就从状态机切到张张二
或者说条件满足的时候
我就做一个动作
把我自己从状态一变成状态二对吧
中间有个叫什么transition
transition里面的话
它有个condition
当condition满足的时候
我就做一个动作
把我的状态切换掉
那我这个时候进入进入到新的状态的时候
我在判断我有其他的
有多少个这个这个这个这个肯定是
只要中间任何一个满足
我就从从这个状态再去transition到下一个状态
那这里面举个很简单的例子
就是比如说像吃豆人对吧
我们要写一个吃豆人的这个AIT行为怎么写诶
大家发现没有
用状态机其实非常的好写
他的逻辑是这样的
就是我呢先乱走一气对吧
这个时候呢
如果我发现我前面有一个ghost出来的时候
我怎么办
哎我这样做
我其实有两条通路
第一条通路是这样的
就是说如果我发现我这个时候就是普通状态
我干嘛
我该怎么办
赶快逃命啊
逃跑对不对
但这个时候如果发现其实我已经吃了药丸
现在进入无敌状态的时候
哎我倒过来去追那个ghost
直到我这个状态结束对吧
那么这个时候如果我在闲晃的过程中
我发现有药丸的话
那我该怎么办
直接上去吃啊对吧
所以其实用一个简单的三个状态
用六条边
我其实就可以做出一个最简单的吃豆人AI
而且我猜测大概率这个吃豆人这个游戏
PARKMAN的话
他的AI最早其实真的是这么写的
换
因为我以前玩过这个游戏
我觉得他的AI是非常predictable
我觉得我们在学那个就是啊计算机那个编程
包括AI的时候
我们第一个作业
我经常记得做AI的作业有这么几个
第一个就是啊写一个吃豆人
AI跟要战胜电脑对吧
还有一个作业是什么呢
就是挖雷
你要自动写个AI算法挖雷
我不知道
同学们
如果有同学们在大学里学computer science
如果学到那AI的时候
最开始的时候很可能会被布置这两个作业
很有意思的好
那这个算法呢其实是非常符合人的直觉
也很经典
但这个CINEMACHINE呢
它其实有个很大的一个问题
什么问题呢
就是说
当我们真的要做一个商业级的游戏的时候
你会发现这个角色的state是非常非常的多
然后呢你每加一个state的时候
你都要去考虑说
它和其他的那些state是个什么关系
你一开始只有七八个十几个的时候
你好好管理
但是想象一下
如果你有几十个上百个state的时候
那些像一团麻花一样的连线
你是不是能够真的搞得清楚怎么连对吧
但是呢你又没有办法
因为你我我们state最复杂的什么叫叫transition
就是说当我发生了一个事情
当一个条件满足的时候
我要迅速的迁到另外一个点去对吧
这就是我因为我要让这个网络非常的reactive
就是反应速度非常的快
那么这里面有没有办法解决呢
其实有的就是那个hierarchy finished in the machine
就是就是层次有限
状态机
就是说我把状态机呢分成很多层
然后呢每一个状态机之间它有一个接口对吧
然后他跟别人都是用有效的接口去跟别人联系
内部维持一个相对可控复杂的状态
这样的好处是什么呢
就是增加了我们状态机的可读性
但是呢它的坏处就是说不好意思
在各个这个这个这个子状态数
那个子状态机里面加很多的非线对吧
我们希望它的出口总是那么几个
所以呢有的时候当然有些情况
比如说我在这个大的这个这个这个这一块里面
如果发生这些情况
我想迅速地跳到另外一个那个那个紫图啊
子状态机里面的某个节点的时候
你除非跳飞线
否则的话呢这个过程其实是比较慢比较慢
所以的话呢虽然说就是hierarchical的
这个FSM的话呢
能不分解决状态机不好维护的问题
但实际上它的反应速度其实是有点问题的
那其实呢这些方法是最古老的
大概是我如果我没记错
大概在15年前那个时候啊
很多时候AI系统还真的是用这个方法去做的
但是呢哎这个差不多在halo20代
黑龙20代
如果我没记错
应该是两千两千零几年
应该2003年还是04年
玩的很早以前了
有一个方法横空出世了对吧
Be ai tree
因为这个方法我是很有感情的
因为我以前做的就是halo
然后当时我在写自己的引擎的时候
当我写到AI这一块的时候
我就打电话问我以前的同事
我说诶状态这个比瑞REE到底是怎么写的
它的要点是什么对吧
真的是就是包着跨洋的电话粥
把这个BEAIREE给他整个湿透了
那么其实行为术这个东西
我相信很多同学们如果对游戏引擎关心的话
都听说过这个大名对吧
那行为术它到底为什么有道理呢
我在before我再去讲行为术这个很细节的时候
我会我会讲一个就是我自己很high level的一个认知
这也是我们课程组的小伙伴
在这一周里面我们准备的时候
我们总结出来的
我们认为其实状态机呢
它是对这整个这个AI的逻辑的一个抽象
他确实我们也可以认为整个世界里面
我们AI的行为就是在状态里面来回切换
但是它并不符合人的真实的世界的思考范围
它不是一个像一团乱麻一样的跳来跳去
而是说我先看看情况嗯
我现在这个当我在这个时候遇到了
没事可干的时候对吧
我遇到了一个
我看看我前面有没有敌人
如果我前面有敌人怎么办
我要判断一下我的状态
我的状态假设是无敌的
那我就去追他
如果我假设我的状态是这个没有Buff的
我马上去掏
你发现没有
当我用语言描述这句话的时候
是不是像一棵棵的树在展开
对不对
其实behavior tree它的设计最核心的一个逻辑
就是他把我们对一个人类的行为的pattern
用状态之间的这种跳转飞线
变成了一个就是一个树状的分支
其实比REE或者叫decision tree吧
这个概念在决策学很早就提出来了
就如果大家真的去研究这一套方法论的
这个历史的时候
其实在啊如果没记错
大家如果学NBA学商务决策的时候
大家可能会学到一个概念叫decision tree
就大家发现
就是说在一些复杂的商业决策的时候
大家之间说诶你为什么做这个角色
你能把你角色的依据输出吗
很多时候大家想一下
比较简单的方法是说我写我的条件12345
所以我的结论是什么
其实这个东西是不科学的
因为这个决策过程是不可以分为什么
条件123你就能得出你这个结论呢
那么在一个更加专业化的
就比如说啊打个比方
比如说军队对吧
我们要有一套作战的
这个我们叫做sop标准作战条例
那么这里面的话呢
其实你在战场上遇到的情况非常的复杂
我如果是这个总参谋部
我想定下来一套作战标准
要求我每一个连排营的指挥官都要这样去
做的时候
他其实就要用一套形式化的这个决策语言
把它表语
把它表达出来
所以人类研发了一个叫decision税的东西
叫决策树的东西
其实就是用这样的一个形式化的分支逻辑
把你该做的动作
各种情况下做的动作把你表达出来了
那么其实呢behavior tree的设计
就是我以前在学习的时候
我认为他的祖宗其实是decision tree
就是决策树好
那么行为术的话呢
你真的去理解它
其实也没有大家想象的那么复杂
那么它的node第一种的话呢就是execution node
就是执行的node
那么执行node你可以认为它全是业界点
那么执行他能做的动作有哪
有哪几种呢
第一种很简单
我做个条件判断
比如说哎
我现在是不是这个有这个ghost在逼近我对吧
或者说我现在是不是在一个powerful的状态里面
对吧
这就是一个判断
在刚才那个书里面
我们会在这边去判断一下
说诶ghost是不是靠近我了
如果ghost靠近我
那我接下来就做一些的动作
对不对
还有就是比如说我发现ghost靠近我了
我问我现在是不是在powerful的状态
如果是yes的话
这是干嘛
我就要做一个动作叫cheese ghost对吧
所以呢接下来还有个什么叫做action node
就是我做一个动作
那么action
但这里面要注意一个细节
就是说我们遇到connote的话
我会瞬间做做成这个判断
我很快就会完成这个判断
但是呢当你做一个动作的时候
比如说我追那个构思的时候
大家想想看我能TIK到这一帧的时候
我就说我要追你好
下一帧的时候我就追到了
不会吧
我这个时候是不是要调用我前面讲的那个
什么navigation系统
我首先要在我和他之间寻个路
对不对
我要去追他
第二个呢我还调用我前面的什么呢
steering系统对吧
要确保我能够这个这个始终正确的
朝着他的方向去加速减速
去逼近它
对不对
那么其实呢这里面我刚才讲的就是ghost
是不是靠近我
就是is close close close的话
实际上是用了什么呢
前面我讲的那个CSIN或者perception系统
帮你告诉你说这个ghost是不是在靠近你
所以呢比AI try的两个业界两种类型的业绩点
一种是条件节点
一种什么呢
是动作节点
但动作节点这里面大家一定要注意一件事情
就是说他是有三种状态
就是说动作成功了对吧
success动作还有什么情况呢
叫失败了
Failed
对不对
FID也很重要
血色素在行为树里面试失败
也是一个很重要的状态
那么第三种是什么呢
诶我们叫做这个i'm running
哥们儿
我正在忙呢
不要打扰我对吧
所以这个是行为树的第一个基础性节点
就是可被执行的node
那么第二种呢就是控制它flow的
其实那个就是行为树的话呢
是一个非常经典的一个就是系统
所以你会发现它的图示都已经标准化了
比如说它能控制它flow呢
有这么四种啊
有三种
其实最经典的其实就三种
第一种是什么呢
叫sequencer
就是顺序执行
你看到的这个箭头
它的意思是什么呢
就是当我走到这个条件的时候
我要依次把我的次数全部执行一遍
诶这个很有意思吧
就顺序执行
那么这个时候如果他此时中间有些人返回
在running的时候
那那个sequence的节点
别人问他
你现在状态怎么样呢
哎我still running对吧
那么这个sequencer他有这个有什么好处呢
它就会让策划
而让设计师非常容易的定义一个计划
就比如说我们从这个就是说
我们要做一件事情的话
那我其实是会依次去做的对吧
待会我会举个更详细的一个例子
那么第二种呢叫selector
selector是什么意思呢
就是根据条件我去尝试我所有的这个子节点
那么我会优先执行在前面那个节点
那这个意思是什么呢
就是说这个前面的最前面的几点
只要执行成功了
我这selection就成功
就相当于是说我到了一个状态的时候
我有三种选择
但三种选择优先级是不一样的
比如说一个士兵
他遇到一个问题
他有三个选择
第一个是消灭敌人对吧
第二个是什么呢
是那个就地这个这个掩护保护自己
第三个什么逃跑
那按照一个士兵的AIT的行为
假设我们讲一个勇敢的士兵的话
他是不是优先的
是要去攻击别人对吧
就是消灭敌人
其次呢是保保存自己
最后才是逃跑
那其实selector这个决策的时候是有就有优先级
那他根据什么决策呢
这里面你可以加入一些判断
比如说我的血量够不够对吧
敌人的武器是不是够强对吧
这些因子在我的书上都可以进行描述
那么第三种呢叫parla parlor呢
就是并行的去执行一件事情
那这里面的话呢
就是说这也是行为树一个很重要的特点
就是说行为树不同于状态机
状态机
你在任何时候你只能在一个状态
但是行为树呢它很强悍的地方
也是适合真实事件的情况
就是我们一个AIT
一个bot可以同时处理很多件事情
我待会会详细的展开
那这里面还有一种control notes
就是我们的decorator
好
我们依次来讲
首先讲什么叫sequencer sequency呢
它实际上就是要求我所有的子节点
依次的去执行它
然后呢当我每一次去问他的时候
我的子节点中间有任何一个人在running
你我我正在跑运动啊
我正在正在运行
那我这个你问我这个sequence的时候
我就是我
我现在下面肯定有我的一个任务
就我一个任务没完成
就怎么去理解这个SEQUENCI
我觉得它就是一个最简单的一个task in系统
就这里面举一个更简单的例子
比如像这里面你看一个AI
它会他要完成一个剧情动作的时候
他首先干嘛
他要给你开门开门
这个动作讲起来很简单
其实比较复杂
你要拆解成第一
我要首先我面前有没有门
对吧
我要做个判断
意思多look at locker
就是门现在是不是锁上
有没有门
门锁上了
第二步是什么
诶
我其实这里面才写的还不够
想更相信的是应该是我走到这个门前
第三步是什么呢
我要unlock这个do
把这个多解锁完
这个任务完成之后呢
我接下来干嘛呢
我要open the door
把这个do打开来
最后一个是什么呢
诶我要首先身先士卒冲冲进去
你会发现没有
就是说如果我们用behavior tree去写的话
用一个sequencer
它其实是可以非常naturally的去表达
这样的一个planning的东西
所以sequence是在BHTREE里面
是个非常重要的基础控制节点
但这里面要注意一个细节
就是说一个sequence节点它最后往上面去反应
就是说它也是三个状态
刚才我讲过第一个啊
我失败了
第二个是什么
我成功了
第三个是我正在running running
好理解
我在这中间任何一个过程
因为比如说一个NPC他去解开一个门
他去推开一个门
他走进去它都不是瞬间完成的
对不对
所以这个时候呢
它实际上都是有一个就是持续时间
在这个过程中呢
只要这些过程没有fail掉
我们都认为你是成功的
但是呢什么时候会fail掉呢
就是这中间的这个这些这些子节点中
只要有任何一个节点反应说我fail掉的话
那这个sequence就非要的
比如说我一上来发现这个门已经开了对吧
install lock的这个东西返回来force
那我接下来所有功能全部不要执行了
那我这个six or直接就跳回去了
你有没有发现这个如果大家想象一下
如果我要去写一个状态机的时候
我依次串了这四个节点对吧
依次去四个state去执行
但是这个state里面
每一次它产生的结果状态主要是force的时候
我是不是要连条飞线回去
到他那个force的处理地方
那你这时候看这个拓扑结构图啊
它其实就比较乱
但是你用一个sequence的节点的话
你会发现他非常的自然和符合人的直觉
那么当我所有的子的子的这个指数
执行返回都是成功的时候
这个时候哎
我就说我这个sequencer顺便成功的完成了
那如果你成功完成之后
那上面的AI也会发生一些其他的变化
好这是sequencer控制节点
很好理解
第二个呢就selector selector
就像我前面讲过的
就是说在这些子节点中的话呢
我们就是说找一个他的这个排放的顺序
你第一个任务完成不了
没关系
我就是第二个对吧
第二个任务完成不了
我就是第三个
但是只要第三个如果完成得了
那好我就是第三个钻下去
只要第三个任务完成之后
我基本上很多大部分selector的话
只要完成一个我就弹回去
但是有些select说我要至少完成两个
但这个其实呢有的时候是不一定的
他们很多时候在这里面的话
我给你们讲一个selector的例子
比如说这里面那个白色的
大家注意看这里那个白色的就是一个小智能体
大家去理解一下
他现在第一步的话
它会判断
就是说哎
我首先判断在我的眼前有没有敌人对吧
如果没有敌人
我做我做一件什么事情呢
我如果有敌人
我做这件事情就是attack
所以我作为一个士兵
勇敢的士兵
我的最高优先级是什么
是打别人
消灭敌人对吧
但如果这个时候这个select的时候
第一个任务失败掉了
就是我没有发现敌人
或者是我attack失败了
怎么办
我就进入了我第二个节点是什么呢
就是我就开始来回巡逻
我就来回走来回走的时候
我这就问问一个问题
就是说我眼前有没有看见敌人
如果敌人是已经看见了
这个时候呢敌人并不哦
不好意思
第一个条件是我的我的可攻击范围里面
有没有敌人对吧
如果攻击范围内有敌人的话
因为我是个近战英雄嘛对吧
那我就马上打他
但是呢
假设这个条件就是在我的晋升没有定点的时候
我就看过第二个条件
就是说我是不是能看见敌人
如果我能看见敌人
那我就进入了我的第二个陷阱
什么呢
我就去追他
我就chase他对吧
那么嘿如果前两个条件都满足
我就进入我的第三个状态是什么呢
我就去patrol去循环
你们去看那个小白人就很有意思
就是他一开始自己来回走对吧
来回走哎
当那个玩家靠的足够近的时候
大家仔细看啊
哎他这时候就打他人
玩家开始逃
玩家逃难
如果因为玩家的速度比他快嘛
当玩家逃出了他的视野的时候
他这时候selector就没事干了
他就进入了他的第三个状态叫patrol
其实这个案例是非常干净和经典的
一个讲select的案例
大家想象一下
反正我是想象过
就是如果这套逻辑让我不用behavior tree
用状态机去写的话
我觉得那个那个状态机做出来的话
其实就算我做对了
它的可读性是很差的
大家仔细想
包括前面我们跟大家讲动画的时候对吧
大家看到那个状态机其实就算一个简单的人呢
走跑跳这个idol的状态的变化
那个状态机就已经很复杂了
那么当我们去定义一个人的行为的时候
其实状态机表达的时候非常的不直观
这个时候大家就能很强烈地感觉到
为什么就行为树这个模型
它其实真的很好理解
但是大家仔细读这个案例
就到时候我们会把这个课程作业给大家
就大家仔细的去看这个案例的时候
你们就能感受到
就是说笔记TRE
它在人类的阅读角度上
是非常的符合我们的认知的好
那最后一个control呢就是说我们叫做PARALA
叫B性化节点
这个事情很有意思诶
不是说状态机要求我们很多时候都在一个状态
为什么这个时候我们能让这个行为树
同时执行两棵子树呢
这就会让我的执行变得非常的混乱
对不对
但这里面也是行为树一个非常重要的一个啊
一个一个一个是我觉得是个很天才的设计
就是说我们观察人类的行为啊
其实人类的行为很多时候它是多线程的
什么意思呢
就是说我们在很多时候
我们的AIT的行为它并不是单一的
他可能是从A点一直走到B点
我在赶路对吧
赶到门口
但我的枪可能会不停的左右循环
如果这个时候我发现有个敌人的时候对吧
我可能用枪开枪
但是呢我的任务是要从A点左边
所以其实我同时在直线两件事情
比如说我现在AI进入的状态是什么
就是说我要赶快去支援我的队友
队友在那个地方
但是呢我要沿途如果发现了敌人
我要开枪去射击对吧
就是要保护好自己
大家想想这是不是我们人的正常的反应
对不对
所以其实这就是behavior tree
它非常符合人类的这个认知
就是说知道我们人其实是一个多线程的
这个物种
但其实所有的bot也是这个逻辑
所以PARALA就这么理解
所以这里面呢就引入了这个
这就是我们的行为术吧
就是大概可以总结一下
这几个几几类节点的这个分布
这里面我就不展开了
因为前面讲的比较细
但是呢这里面我要讲一个很重要的一个点
就是说行为术
他在每一个tick就这里面讲的是引擎的
同学们要注意了
就每个tick的时候
你怎么去TIK
在前面我们讲到的动画树也好
讲的很多的树也那个蓝图也好
它它其实更像状态机
就是它总是会停在一个状态对吧
下一次TK来的时候
我会从当前这个状态开始继续往后去找个个的
就是condition
说这个我的边
我的连出去的边的
肯定是只要满足了我的状态机发生切换
对不对
那么这个效率是很高的
但是行为树这个时候他的问题就来了
就是行为术
你要去taking他的时候
要像人一样
他每一次都会从根节点重新开始去TIK
因为这个时候当你现在在做一个任务A的时候
在做一个action a的时候
假设这个时候出现了一个新的情况
你action a其实没有做完
比如像刚才那个那个
就是那个啊小吃豆人的案例
比如说你那个小人
你现在还在巡逻
但是下一帧的时候
你突然发现你面前出现了一个敌人对吧
你这个时候应该要把那个巡逻的那个action要打断
不是把它做完
因为那个那个任务可能是无限循环的对吧
那个action是无限循环的
你要把它打断
然后呢进入到我行为树的下一个分支
有的时候那是相当的像polo的话
他有的时候是什么
会同时执行两个行为树啊
两两个行为次数
所以说行为术大家始终牢记一个一个关键点
就是说啊其实两个点
第一点就是说每一次tick它的时候
你要从根节点重新去TIK它
否则你肯定会写出很多AI的bug
第二件事情是什么呢
就是说行为术同时在running的节点
可以可能不止一个
可能它激活激活的节点有很多个
同时在激活
只要符合你的规范
当然了
我们会看到有些游戏引擎
它对这个事情做了一个优化
因为这个电话产生一个问题
就是说使得我们行为术每一次契合的时候
成本非常的高
你得反复的对吧
你想想如果这个这个AIT的行为很大
是一个很大的数
你结果每一次每一帧的时候要从头开始tick
所以呢像有些引擎里面他做了个优化
就是说你还是从当前这些激活的节点去去tick
但是他做了一些event
就是当这些event发生的时候
有一些此树会直接被激活
甚至是直接整棵树被激活重新替换一遍
但这个呢
其实我认为是对传统的行为树做了一个优化
这个优化本身我认为也是非常合理的
但是他这边产生的一个小问题
就是说设计师呢他必须对这个东西很清楚
否则的话他如果没有做这些激活的event的话
这个行为树的行为可能就会出错
你会发现你的bot在很傻的在做同一件事
你明明发现诶
这个比如说这个你在这个bot在前面前面砍人
这个时候主将已经发出指令了
说你要跟我来
但是那个那个那个那个bot还在傻乎砍
因为他要把那个人砍完
这个任务完成
就把那个敌人砍死
任务完成之后
他才跟着主角跑
但是我们人类的行为认知是说
虽然你现在砍人了
对不对
但是你听到你的这个呃主将发出指令说
跟我走的时候
他应该是尽快的这个把刀收起来
撒腿就跟着你跑对吧
所以其实他那个行为是要被打断的
而且他前面一整套角色的话
要从前面开始跑起来
所以的话呢这是行为树的一个在ticking的时候
很重要的一个点
OK好
那么其实呢行为术其实传经典的定义啊
其实五类节点基本上就够了
但是呢这里面要跟大家讲一下
就行为术其实后面大家都做了很多的优化
刚才我讲的就是在效能上大家有优化
就是说可以用event去驱动部分
但其实还有一个重要的东西叫decorator戴AI
他很多人做什么呢
他就是说加上一些我们很常用的东西
比如说我希望这个action还会loop对吧
我希望这个action呢稍微等一下
不要马上就发生对吧
我希望呢这个action呢能够修改一些环境变量
这些这些杂七杂八的零碎的东西的话
我们用一个decorator能解决
它
就是一个DEXTER
你挂上去之后
你可以做各种几类不同的动作
这里面给大家举个简单的例子
比如说我们希望一个一个人在巡逻
一会儿是A点
一块是B点对吧
那大家想想这个东西很简单
是一个sequencer对吧
A到B
但是呢我们希望它到每个目标点之后呢
它能够先停个一秒
那如果用传统的这个行为术去做的话
我们要加四个节点C课程
比如说等一秒
然后呢移动到A点好呢
到了A点之后
再等一秒移动到B点
我以此循环
对不对
哎
但是如果用DECORA就很简单
我在这个物的A的B前面我加一个小小的修饰
说兄弟仅等一秒我们再来
就决定往前走
所以其实DECORA很多时候就是
它并不是一个什么新的这个数据结构
它只是让我们的这个行为树的话呢
读起来更加的简洁
包括行为术后来很多的优化
比如说我们给每个行为加一个precondition对吧
就是A其实会把很多的不必要的那个条件
分支给它省掉
就相当于这个分支
我的下去是你的precondition满足了
我就我就直接往下走
如果不满足的话
我直接返回一个false
这样这个数看上去更简洁了好
所以呢就是说哦我我这边已经提前讲到了
实际上这个地方讲的就是precondition的概念
就是说如果引入了一个precondition的话
刚才像那棵比较复杂的树
就是那个啊吃豆人的这个案例嘛
你就会变得这么简单
就是说哎我一个selector
就是说我面前有没有看见那个ghost对吧
如果ghost完全没有看见
直接跳到后面
那个就是说我这个就是啊去找药丸去
如果这个时候我看到这个ghost的话
判断第一我现在是不是在proper状态
如果是的话
我就去追ghost
如果我不在post
我就直接逃跑
你看看刚才那么一个补起来还是有点那么小
费劲的那棵树
现在变成了它的可靠性是不是高了很多
所以我们在讲什么叫行为树
这个这个这个数据结构它的核心是什么
就是说在数学上
我个人认为呢啊他没有什么特别的
这个就是特别的地方
但是他最了不起的一个地方
就是说他真的把设计师设计这个AIT的行为
变成一个人类好去理解好去维护的东西了
所以说这个这个地方实际上有很多
很巧妙的设计思维
另外一个
我觉得它的设计美学上有个很美的地方
就是说他只用了这种五类节点对吧
就能够几乎把我们想到所有的这个AIT的行为
都能给它定义出来
其实你们会发现我们人类在做很多事情的时候
它就是一个分支决策
分支决策的行为
其实大家如果有机会学那个战略
比如说啊企业经营啊
或者是军事的那个部队的军事训练上
也是一种叫军事决策的话
其实他们用的也是一种决策树模型
其实跟我们的行为术模型是还蛮像的好
那么在行为树里面的话
还有一个很重要的概念
就是那个BLACKWORD
就是个黑板
什么意思呢
就是说其实这个在我们的这个前面讲的
game play系统里面已经隐隐的提到
就是说其实在整个游戏跑的过程中间
它会产生很多的环境变量
就是说当我做了一个行为
我可能会修改这个环境变化
比如说我下一个行为我是攻击了别人
那这个别人到底有没有被杀死呢
如果我现在返回
我是一个这个我现在还在running
但是呢我想告诉别人说这个是敌人
我其实已经杀死了
那我下一次AI角色的时候
可能根据说我刚刚杀死一个敌人
我这是干嘛
我要做一个庆祝动作对吧
那我心中动作播完之后
我要把我杀死的那个状态给清洗掉
那这在这个分支数的两个不同的分支的时候
我们怎么去交换信息呢
哎这时候我们会做个黑板
这个黑板的话呢
其实非常像我们之前讲的event系统一样
就是说他用一个IDE
用一个名字和他各种多态的数据去表达
然后行为树的不同节点
他去消费这些数据
所以呢这是这个就是你行为术
我们认为最后一个building block基本上讲到这儿的话
同学们想想看是不是已经有点急不可耐了
我终于学完了navigation对吧
我终于学完了这个寻路
那个那个pass finding的寻路
我学完了这个就是说对环境的感知
我学完了steering
然后呢
终于老师教我了这个这个这个要么用状态机
要么用行为术
其实这个时候实话实说
你可以作为一个简单的很好玩的游戏了
包括为什么我对讲AI讲的这么热心啊
就是因为我觉得这个地方是真的是很好玩
真的是非常好玩
就是如果大家不想写那么复杂的渲染对吧
那么复杂的这个动画系统
那么复杂的物理系统
还有游戏逻辑体系
光就AI这一块写起来是非常游戏
而且你可以根据自己的想象
构建各种各样的游戏
那么所以说呢呢
行为术是一个非常好的一个系统了
就像我们前面讲了
它的好处特别多
就是特别符合人类的认知
而且呢很好维护
另外一个很大的好处
就是它DEPAR也很方便
因为它真的是就是可以你观察一个AI的行为
我可以直接告诉你说哪些节点被激活了
这里面我展示的这个虚幻的行为术
的一个案例吗
就是他会这个有的行为术
比如说它是从左向右的对吧
有的行为术呢是从上向下
这都不重要
这都是细节
重要的是它基本的逻辑
是符合这样的一个结构的
那么但是行为术的一个它其实也有一个缺点
这个缺点的话呢就是这样
我们前面讲到的就是说啊
他每一次tick如果不做优化的话
都从根节点开始
那这个东西的话呢其实是这个比较废的
好行为术是不是完美的呢
包括为什么我们AI讲完这么多了
我们还要再讲下一节课呢
这里面就是我也算留一个
就是这个最last word吧
就是给大家讲一句
为什么我们要讲
下节课给大家讲一个非常high level的东西
其实大家有没有发现啊
无论是状态机也好
行为术也好
有一种叫什么呢
叫做神挡杀神
佛挡杀佛
就是我遇到这个情况
所以我就怎么怎么干
我干到一半又发生了新情况
所以我就又怎么怎么干
其实这种感觉就像什么呢
就像是我是个robot对吧
其实我没有思想
没有灵魂
我只是遇到情况
主人告诉我说我该怎么处理
我就怎么处理
所以它的好处是什么呢
确定性非常高
但是它的坏处是什么呢
There's no purpose
就是没有目的
但是我们人类在思考所有的问题在说什么
我们是有目标的对吧
那么所以呢在下一节课
我们我们会跟大家讲的一系列的
其他的这个前沿的决策算法
包括就是基于深度学习的一些方法
其实这里面有一个跟这个算法
它有很大的一个转变是什么呢
就是说他会把我们现在所有可以做的动作
变成就是一个选项
然后呢我根据世界的状态
我要形成我的什么呢
我的目标
我要我的目标
比如说我的目标是要做一个优秀的战士
所以我要杀足够多的敌人
那所以呢我的规划就是要在战场上
寻找到敌人最密集的地方
其实我要打得过对吧
这个时候我要保护好自己
把敌人消灭
大家听一下
这个东西是不是更像我们人的人去思考
所以你会发现就是当AI研究到这一步的时候
我们会发现传统的无论是状态机也好
还是行为树算法
它更像像像我刚才讲他是个forward的方法
就是脚踩西瓜皮
走到一步是一步推导的方derive算法
但是的话呢其实我们人类在做很多动作的时候
我们是个逆向的过程
因为我有个目标对吧
我为了考上大学
所以呢我要好好学习
我要我好好学习呢
我就必须要学完数理化对吧
数学要从最低级的高级的开始
中间我要做习题
我要做很多动作
所以这里面就有一个go目标和planning的问题
所以这就是我们下节课要讲的一些前沿的AI
算法的话
他的设计思想
所以这里面就会有一些搜索
就会有一些planning
就是规划的问题对吧
包括我们要用一些深度学习的算法
能解决我们部分的东西
所以下节课的话呢
我个人还是非常的期待
我觉得非常的有意思好
那今天讲到这儿的话
我今天已经讲了哇
我又创了个新纪录
今天我们讲了两个小时
差不多15分钟
那今天我们课程的主题到此结束
到此结束
那再次呢就是这个这些的话
是我们今天的那个所有的参考论文
那同学们都会发现
就是说哎
这一节课的参考论文的数量是比较多的
确实是基本上每一个算法
大家的话呢如果想深度了解的话
你会发现这里面有很多的文章
大家可以去读
这就是游戏引擎的魅力
就是说它确实是一个很深的一个东西
那再送我们要感谢一下我们的课程组
其实我们课程的小伙伴已经绝对不止这些同学
对吧
大家这段时间你想我们能写出180页的PPT
这简直是这个我我觉得我们的概率还是很大的
那么好
那最后的话呢就进入我们的QA环节了
同学们有什么问题
好的OK好
我看到了啊
第一个问题来了
就是说啊行为术和if else有什么区别
这个问题问的太太厉害了
就是说就行为术和我们在写高级语言的
这个if else的这个分支有什么区别
其实呢一大家如果去理解这个if else的话呢
其实它就是一个最简单的行为术对吧
它实际上你可以认为它完全是由这个
就是叫selector构成的一个数
就是我往下走
if条件满足了
我就做什么动作
如果不满足
我就选择下一个
对吧好
我就往下钻
每一次都这样
你可以认为if else是行为术的一个特殊情况
但是就像我刚才讲的
就是如果你用if else的话呢
你很难去写一个planning
当然你可以说衣服这个条件满足了
我
请一一次执行下面的动作
这个动作过程中间我说衣服发生了什么事
这个时候我们该怎么办
诶这个时候大家如果学习高级语言
有一个指令叫做其实不是高级语言
汇编里面就有这个指令叫什么呢
叫go to对吧
或者叫jump
其实行为术它的设计
如果你真的强行的用if else去模拟的话
你会发现你的代码中有很多的衣服
什么条件满足了我
go to或者降不到一个什么地方
所以这就讲我就讲语言的美妙的地方
就是说他在数学上大家都是等价的
但是的话呢行为树的这个表达
会更符合人类的这种规划感
人类的这种就是说啊就这种条件来了之后
我会各种反射或者中断的那种感觉
所以说啊这是我理解啊
就行为术和衣服else的区别好
希望这个回答让同学们满意啊
然后第二个就是说同学们问我的是说是不是AI
怎么去这个就是sensing
就是从环境里提取数据
其实这个问题如果从很专业的角度上讲
就是说呃
当我们做一个真实的游戏
或者游戏引擎的这个AI系统
其实对环境的perception
这件事情并不像大家想的那么简单
其实他会他有两个大的挑战
第一个挑战呢就在我的课程中已经提到
就是说来自于环境的数据真的是异构的
多种多样
有的时候你读的是一个变量对吧
有的时候你读的是一个数值
有的时候你读的是一个true false
有的时候呢你读的是一个空间上的坐标点
有的时候你读的是一串数组
比如说我当前所有可见的敌人是不是一串数组
对不对
就几人的id
哎有的时候你读的是什么呢
是一张图
比如说我读的读进来的一张infant map
我要对这个图还进行query对吧
所以这些异构数据怎么在我的AI体系里面
用一套统一的语法去表达和获取
其实这对于你的引擎设计是有一点点挑战
但是其实在前面大家如果听到我们讲反射呀
去讲到这个event系统的这个payload设计啊
其实隐隐能感觉到
其实用这套其实我们是能解决的
那么第二个是什么呢
就是第二个阶段
就是说其实AIT在获取环境的数据的时候
实际上的话效率比他想象的要低很多很多
为什么
比如说我们做一群能战斗的AI at
它真的在一个几百个就是战场里面
有几百个AIT在一起的时候
我眼睛看过去
其实每一个AI at它都能看到至少几十个敌人
对不对
这个数量其实还是比较保守的
那我有几百个AIT看到几十个敌人的时候
这时候你发现没有
我要读上万个G的数据到我的AI里面去
然后呢这AI呢我不仅是只是读他的id啊
我还读什么呢
读他的tm id
就是说他跟我是敌是友啊
第二个就是说诶他现在是什么状态呀对吧
他现在是不是有武器啊对吧
包括那个他现在离我的距离远近啊
我现在能够得着它
比如说他现在是不是残血还是我残血啊
对不对
你会发现就是当我真的做一个AI决策的时候
我要不大量的复合数据
那这些数据的从系统中query
实际上是一个很废的事情
所以说我们在做AI行为的时候
我们很多时候是要对世界的这个数据的
perception的话
是要做指令的规划和处理的
所以的话呢这是我认为就是AI读指令的
这个行为的话
两个设计上的一个难点
就是也供大家去参考
那第三个问题我看有什么问题啊
如何处理垂直零界面的novation mesh的生成
哎呀我的天呐
这个就是很难的一个问题了
首先这个垂直零界面他讲的
如果你讲的是这样的一个一个直倒角的话
呃按照那个比如说一些经典的navigation
match的算法的话呢
他要么就直接越过去了
比如说你的垂直面不是特别高
他就直接越过去
认为你是可以直接通行的
如果是特别高的话呢
他会认为这个地方就断掉了对吧
他就在下面形成了一个navigation mesh
上面也会形成一个navigation mesh
如果大家讲的是这个问题
那么就所以说的话呢
其实反正我们自己用这个navigation mesh
生成算法的时候
一般到种垂直零界面
都是我们觉得最痛苦的一个问题
那么当然如果比如说啊就像我讲的
就是我们有的时候会处理一些像攀爬的问题
在引擎里面这个地方我们一般的做法是什么呢
就是说在引擎里会提供一套工具
让这个设计师能够标记一些可攀爬的点
这些点我会标把标记它的端点
就是说你在无论你在下面还是在上面
你都可以知道到这我就可以攀爬
当然到这儿的话
整个寻路的行为
包括这个人物的动作
它都会发生变化
比如说你在平地上走
那你的这个比如说NPC它是正常走的背
但一到那个地方变成攀爬的时候
它可能要把武器背到背上对吧
这个手开始开始抓着墙
开始爬
爬到顶上的时候
还要做一个诶翻身上墙的这么一个动作
那你上去是一组
对不对
下来还是一组
而且呢这些数据就是说垂直面的零界面的话
如果我是用这种方法生成的话呢
我们一般会把这个数据不要存在navigation mesh里面
我直接存在这个word space的坐标里面
这样的话呢当我的环境
比如说其他人去改的时候
因为他每一次生成的vacation mesh都会不一样
所以这些信息是没办法保留的
所以我只能把它存在世界坐标系里面对吧
然后这样每一次NEC版生成之后
我那个地方再给他补一下
要么用NAVI把它连上去
要么我加一些
就刚才我讲的那个就是特殊的这个江湖point
把它跳过去
所以这个地方的话呢是一个就是真实在实战中
大家用的gsh mesh的话
就会遇到很多很恶心的case
这些其实也是很做游戏引擎很挑战的一件事
就是玩家玩的时候天天会骂
说你的AI有很多的bug
但是我们真的在做系统设计
做这个底层技术的团队
就知道你想把它做到符合大家的期望
其实有很多的技术挑战
好的
那今天的话呢就是说呃我先回答了这么多问题
因为今天时间确实有点长了
那再次谢谢大家
就是说能够那个就是那个听完我们这么长的课
那下一节课呢我们会讲高级的AI的一些技术
那么争取的话呢
我们用三节课的时间
把整个玩法系统和AI系统给大家讲透好
谢谢大家下次见